Okay, let's move on now to the possible escalation
with Iran.
Donald Trump is straight up threatening war
crimes against Iran on Twitter.
He's doing it casually.
He's not trying to hide it.
Let's look at the declaration.
This was made of course, on Twitter, which
has become strangely normal in 2020 under
Donald Trump.
Not only is policy communicated on Twitter,
but also threats of war crimes are communicated
on Twitter, Twitter, Donald Trump saying quote,
Iran is talking very boldly targeting certain
USA assets as revenge for our ridding the
world of their terrorist leader who had just
killed an American and badly wounded many
others.
Not to mention all of the people he had killed
over his lifetime, including recently hundreds
of Iranian protesters.
He was already attacking our embassy and preparing
for additional hits in other locations.
Iran has been nothing but problems for many
years.
Let this serve as a warning that if Iran strikes
any Americans or American assets, we have
targeted 52 Iranian sites representing the
52 American hostages taken by Iran many years
ago.
Some at a very high level and important to
Iran and the Iranian culture and those targets
and Iran itself will be hit very fast and
very hard.
The USA wants no more threats.
That's a war crime.
Okay.
Targeting sites of cultural importance to
Iran.
It's not open to interpretation.
We criticized ISIS for doing it.
There is a widely sourced Wikipedia article
where there are lists of mosques and libraries
and ancient and medieval sites, churches,
monasteries, all sorts of sites that ISIS
destroyed and when they do it, we are very
clear these are war crimes.
They can't do this.
We must stop them and then our president threatens
to do the exact same thing casually on Twitter.
The president is tweeting out that he will
commit war crimes on Twitter and nearly half
the country pretends this as normal.
There have actually been convictions on war
crimes, charges for intentionally destroying
cultural sites.
Uh, Ahmad all Faki al-Mahdi, uh, was, um,
uh, tried at the international criminal court
in the Hague, Netherlands, um, for the destruction
of historic mazal Liam's in the Malian desert
of Timbuktu.
And Marty ultimately pleaded guilty to his
Trump looking to be both impeached and, uh,
tried at the Hague and now an American president
being convicted of war crimes is of course
not likely.
George W. Bush good.
A good candidate for war crimes charges.
Nothing happened.
Nothing is going to happen.
It is hard to believe, but increasingly Iran
seems to have the least legal and moral high
ground here.
Trump would the unauthorized assassination
followed by threatening war crimes.
The deliberate destruction of cultural sites
Trump up, uh, pulling out of the Iran nuclear
deal without Iran having done anything.
It's crazy because we share with the audience,
I mean many concerns about this theocratic
regime in Iran, which I have opposed for,
you know, publicly for more than a decade.
It is stunning that we have someone so depraved
and so immoral running our country that in
this narrow set of circumstances, they seem
to have the legal and moral high ground.
Now, one other note on this, I hope to have
time to talk about this later this week, this
entire thing wreaks of evangelical Christianity
and its underlying notion because again, attacking
Muslim cultural sites, uh, going after, uh,
an, uh, a regime, even if it's by proxy that
evangelical Christians see as the bad one.
You know, evangelical Christians have this
thing where even though many of them are inherently
antisemitic, they are often very pro Jewish
because they see supporting Jews as maybe
a way to get the second coming of PR.
I mean, it's crazy, right?
It's completely bonkers.
But it leads to many evangelicals, uh, supporting
Jews.
Even if in a way that many Jews are not that
interested in, in, in having that support,
certainly I, I would fall under that umbrella.
The, uh, American Christian right is absolutely
licking their chops over the possibility of
war with Iran and a lot of this stuff reeks
of evangelical Christianity.
We'll see if we have time for that.
Maybe Wednesday on the program tomorrow.
The Tuesday show is already almost full because
so much is going on.
We will have continued coverage of this on
the David Pakman show Instagram page with
nearly 25,000 of our viewers and listeners.
Now following our content there,
uh, David Pakman show on Instagram.
While you're there, follow me@daviddotpacmanaswellthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com